There are so many strong opinions
about how bad the internet has become.
How it has weaponized mediocrity.
Normalized mis- and disinformation.
But for me,
the information superhighway
has always been my savior.
As a little boy,
I was sent from Nigeria to boarding school
in the English countryside.
It was like "Harry Potter"
without the magic.
(Laughter)
It was a confusing and troubling time
for an already sensitive little boy
who was far from home.
I was more like
an exotic animal in a petting zoo
rather than a student.
And to top it off, I'm dyslexic
and today what would be described
as neurodiverse,
which for me meant that the classroom
was impossibly slow
and my brain was not capable
of assimilating how they were teaching me.
So for a big part of my life,
I was ashamed of my own mind.
And if I'm being honest,
I was ashamed of myself.
Luckily, the internet had other ideas.
Every time I consumed something online,
my brain felt alive.
It was an awakening of sorts.
And luckily for me,
I am the right age to have discovered
the internet in that very, very moment.
So what did I start doing?
I started realizing how my mind worked.
How I could assimilate audiovisual
experiences intensely.
How I could name a song
within the first second or the first note.
Or talk about scenes in films
like I lived them.
And how overwhelmingly powerful
artistic experiences were for me.
This became my savior.
And I wanted to share it with my friends.
So pop ballads like
"More Than Words" by Extreme.
Street poetry like
“Brenda’s Got a Baby” by Tupac.
Films like "The Last of the Mohicans,"
"Love Jones,"
and of course, "Cinema Paradiso."
These experiences were way more
than entertainment for me.
I was being raised by these experiences,
and I needed to share it
with as many people as possible.
So my friends would come
with their hard drives,
and I would download and share pictures
and poetry and film for them.
For me, the internet had become
an endless library of the extraordinary.
And I didn't just have the keys
to this library.
I lived there.
We would talk about Fela Kuti,
Joni Mitchell, Neil Young.
These were my heroes.
These were the souls
that have found the blueprint
of how to do and win
in this thing called life.
It also saved my mental health.
The dancing of Misha Baryshnikov
was for me, like watching
a perfect sunset.
The voice of Sarah Vaughan
was my North Star.
And of course, the words of Pablo Neruda?
Well, that will always be
medicine for my soul.
So,
how did I get to be
this great observer of content
and become an artist?
It was just sharing images.
And one of the images I shared
all the time was this image
of Coretta Scott King.
This image was taken by Moneta Sleet Jr.,
the first Black man to win
a Pulitzer for photography.
This image almost didn't happen
because unbelievably,
no Black media was invited
to photograph the funeral
of Dr. Martin Luther King.
When Coretta Scott realized, she said,
"No one's coming into this church
if Moneta Sleet is not allowed."
And thank the heavens that he was,
because it was his lens
that captured the grace
and somehow, on an unimaginable day,
the strength of Coretta Scott King
on the funeral of her husband
with her baby girl, Bernice, in her lap.
It was this image that taught me
that photography can be way more
than wedding pics and birthday snaps.
It was this image that let me know
that at its best,
photography can let us know
the work that we need to do.
(Applause)
So how did I become
an actual photographer?
Well, the answer of that is love.
My wife.
We fell in love together
by feeling each other’s
invisible scars like braille.
She fell in love
with all the parts of myself
that I was ashamed of.
She looked beyond my anxiety,
my imposter syndrome,
and she saw a man that maybe
had a point of view himself.
So she bought me a camera
for my 40th birthday.
Just five years ago.
So I have a camera now,
I don't know what to do with it.
And once again, I go online,
and I teach myself about ISO
and aperture on YouTube.
I teach myself about editing
with Adobe Lightroom on YouTube.
And there's a great beauty
for someone like me
to be able to fail and fail
in my little office, online,
watching free tutorials.
This is a gift of the internet.
Everything changed
when my daughter was born.
You see, the thing
about not loving yourself
is that when something truly great,
something celestial,
like a child, comes into your life,
you tell yourself you don't deserve it.
My daughter was premature,
and I was terrified to be the custodian
of something so beautifully precious.
So I hid behind my camera.
And as I kept taking pictures of this
little soul and as she got stronger,
the camera and my daughter
taught me how to receive love
and taught me to accept
the immense grace and privilege
of being a father.
This was the most important moment
in my photographic journey.
Two years later, in 2020,
George Floyd was killed.
And all of us saw that
because of the power of social media.
And this time we refused to look away.
I looked to my wife and I said,
“I have run out of tears.”
And she said, "Look to your camera."
And I took my camera
to the streets of London,
not knowing if I would photograph
five people or 5,000.
And I was able to observe
one of the greatest civil rights
movements in our lifetime.
The global protests
after the death of George Floyd
is something none of us
would have expected.
And my lens was there.
One morning I woke up
and I couldn’t open my phone
because I had so many notifications.
The son of Coretta Scott King,
Martin Luther King III,
had somehow come across one of my images
and posted it on his Twitter.
And then the world discovered me.
(Applause)
Millions of people saw these images
and now, unbelievably,
British “Vogue” came calling,
and they commissioned
a then-unknown photographer
to shoot the September issue
of British "Vogue" 2020.
And in doing so, I became
the first Black man
to shoot any cover for British "Vogue."
(Applause)
It took 104 years to get to my cover.
Since then, I've had
this extraordinary career
photographing amazing humans,
amazing moments.
But beyond all the glitz
and all the glamour,
it is really important for me
to recognize the intentionality
and the empathy
of where my lens must look.
The world is burning right now
and we cannot pass each other by
like ships in the night.
So my lens has to look
to where voices need to be lifted.
I recently have become an ambassador
for Save the Children.
And I went to Somaliland
to cover the famine,
the hunger crisis
that is in the Horn of Africa.
These brave people are suffering
because of climate change,
something that they add very little to.
Many of the children
are born into a hellscape
that is not of their making.
1.6 million children
are on the verge of acute malnutrition.
And I want my images to let you know
that you cannot say you did not know.
So I ask you to use whatever levers
of power that you have,
at dinner parties, on your social media,
speak to those that can do
something about it
if you cannot yourself.
I will finish by saying this.
Do not be afraid to take
the road less traveled.
Wear your vulnerability with pride.
It is what makes us human.
This age of perceived perfection,
it's over.
Very few of us are OK, and that's OK.
And to the parents and teachers
that are looking after children
with different minds,
please let them know about the power
and possibility of their minds.
Because they may have the answers
that will allow all of us
to look toward the horizon together.
Thank you.
(Applause)